bonjour bruno megaman merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu un juste avant les chiffres
augmentent de plus en plus le nombre de
patients admis à l'hôpital également est
ce qu'aujourd'hui les hôpitaux de france
son prêt en cas de forte affluence
oui tout à fait les hôpitaux de france
et notamment en ile-de-france sont
préparés effectivement pour accueillir
les nouveaux patients infectés par la
coved 19 qui présenteraient des formes
graves de pneumonie
donc l'objectif que nous avons c'est
d'essayer de maintenir tant que ce peut
également la filière des patients non
infectés par l'aco vide et donc de
permettre d'assurer les soins pour la
totalité des patientes qui viendrait à
l'hôpital alors dans les semaines qui
arrivent on s'attend à de plus en plus
de cas positifs 1 c'est déjà le cas et
puis de nouveau à patients dans les
hôpitaux de france à ce que d'après vous
la période va être aussi tendue qu'en
mars avril dernier alors il est peu
probable que nous ayons un nombre aussi
massif de patients qu'ovide 19 qui
arrive au même moment et que les
services hospitaliers soit débordé
néanmoins la difficulté
cette fois ci c'est qu'il va y avoir une
concomitance entre l'épidémie de par la
coved 19 et les épidémies habituel
hivernale virale et notamment la grippe
généralement l'hiver
l'ensemble des patients qui ont des
pathologies respiratoires
cardiovasculaires chroniques peuvent des
compensées en raison du froid et des
virus saisonniers et donc
malheureusement cette année il va y
avoir une coïncidence de l'épidémie par
la copie de 19 et de ses des
compensations c'est pourquoi évidemment
il va y avoir un besoin très important
de lits et de personnels soignants pour
pouvoir assurer la prise en charge de
tous les patients
qui nécessitent d'être hospitalisé
justement est-ce que ça va être pas un
peu plus compliqué cette année pour vous
personnels hospitaliers de faire la
différence entre le coût 8 19 et puis
toutes ces maladies infectieuses dont
vous dont vous parliez qui arrive à
l'hiver généralement alors c'est vrai
c'est c'est une des complications qui
nous attend effectivement là les
personnes vont se présenter aux médecins
traitants au service d'urgence avec des
tableaux similaires c'est à dire de la
fièvre des maux de gorge le nez qui
coule de la fatigue de la toux de
l'essoufflement effectivement avec ce
tableau clinique
on va devoir faire la part entre ce qui
revient à la copie de 19 et ce qui
revient au virus habituels hivernaux
alors bien sûr nous disposons de tests
diagnostiques sensible et puissant pour
pouvoir le faire mais c'est vrai qu'il
va y avoir un embouteillage à la fois
des patients aux urgences mais également
un embouteillage des prélèvements au
niveau des laboratoires et doux bien sûr
notre recommandation de se faire
vacciner très largement par le vaccin de
la grippe lorsque celui ci sera
disponible pour éviter de devoir se
retrouver aux urgences est évidemment
compliqué la prise en charge
alors vous vous le savez très
certainement des restrictions ont été
mises en place dans plusieurs villes de
france est le cas à lyon à bordeaux à
nice ou encore au havre met pas de
restrictions particulières pour
l'instant en tout cas à paris là où le
virus circule rapidement est ce que est
ce que ça vous étonne alors je dirais
bon je crois que les autorités
sanitaires observer les chiffres de
façon très rapprochée
j'ai bien peur malheureusement que la
situation de paris soit ex en droite
ligne avec celle de marseille et de lyon
d'ailleurs depuis
24 48 heures le taux d'incidence des
nouveaux cas de contamination à paris a
ainsi qu'en seine saint denis a dépassé
celui des bouches du rhône et donc il
est à craindre évidemment que cette
augmentation d'incidence des nouveaux
cas
sa compagne rapidement d'une
augmentation des admissions à l'hôpital
d'ailleurs nous observons déjà cette
tendance pour vous donner un exemple à
l'hôpital lariboisière
plus de la moitié des lits de la
réanimation sont déjà occupés par des
patients gravement affectée par la coved
alors ce soir le ministre de la santé
oliveira fera un point à 19h sur
l'augmentation des cas avec peut-être de
nouvelles restrictions qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ce discours du ministre
de la santé
j'allais dire il sera il est toujours
important évidemment de rappeler les
fondamentaux pour nos concitoyens et
notamment l'importance des mesures
barrières du port du masque universelle
est essentiellement dans les lieux clos
pour éviter la diffusion du virus
il est aussi très important d'être très
vigilants lors des rassemblements privé
par exemple les soirées entre amis les
soirées entre étudiants car ce sont dans
ces lieux que se fait la diffusion du
virus et par la suite ces jeunes
personnes qui présentent des formes peu
symptomatiques voire totalement
asymptomatiques sans le savoir véhicule
le virus vers des personnes plus
sensibles plus âgé que nous voyons
désormais arriver en réanimation avec
des tableaux aussi grave que lors de la
premier pic épidémique
merci beaucoup bruno m'égare banda voir
est avec nous on l'aura compris est donc
la prudence est toujours de mise merci
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes chef du service animation à
l'hôpital lariboisière